.
>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY AND THAT
MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLEYS.
FOR THAT WE TURN TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ROYO.
THIS HAS BEEN A WEEK OF
PROTESTS.
>> CLIMATE ACTIVIST SMASH ADD
CAKE IN THE FACE OF KING CHARLES
OR A WAX WORK OF KING CHARLES.
>> IT'S A SYMBOL.
JUST STOP.
IT'S A PIECE OF CAKE.
>> HIS SON HARRY IS ABOUT TO
SMASH THE KING WITH A CAKE OF A
DIFFERENT SORT AND RELEASING A
NEW MEMOIR CALLED SPARE AND
ALLEGEDLY UNSPARING ACCOUNT OF
THE DUKE OF SUSSEX'S TRUTH, MY
TRUTH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT TITLE,
LAURA, SPARE THAT HE WOULD CALL
THE BOOK SPARE?
>> Laura: WELL, HE'S SUPPOSED
TO HAVE AIR AND SPARE JUST TO BE
SAFE; RIGHT.
I GUESS HE WAS USING THAT AS
KIND OF A PLAY ON BEING THE
SPARE HEIR.
>> PRINCESS ANNE IS THE SPARE,
THE SISTER OF PRINCE CHARLES AND
SHE'S THE BACKUP SHOULD ANYTHING
HAPPEN AND MORE AND I WANT TO
ALSO POINT OUT THAT IN ADDITION
TO LOOKING LIKE A VIDEO GAME
AVATAR ON THE COVER OF HIS BOOK,
MIS-COVER LOOK -- HIS COVER
LOOKS LIKE A COMPANION PIECE TO
MEGHAN MARKLE'S PIECE AND HIS
GHOST WRITER IS THE ONE THAT
ANDRE AGASI BOOK OPEN AND GOT
THE SAME FULL FACE TREATMENT AND
IT'S THE TREND OF CELEBRITY
RATHER THAN ROYALTY.
>> I THINK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER IF IT WAS CALLED WHIPPED.
>> Laura: HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S
KIND OF THE POOR GUY IS ALWAYS
IN THE SHADOW OF HIS WIFE.
NOT THAT THERE'S ANYTHING WRONG
WITH THAT APPARENTLY ANYMORE.
>> OR CALL IT HAD LADY IN
WAITING AND WAS BEHIND MARKLE.
>> Laura: SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PEEKING OUT FROM ONE OF HER
BEAUTIFUL BALL GOWNS.
JUST PEEKING OUT.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN GOOD TOO.
THERE'S ANOTHER PROTEST IN WEEK
AND ANOTHER CLIMATE IDIOT GLUED
HIMSELF TO VERSUS FREQUENCY
MERE'S GIRL WITH A PEARL EARRING
AND AN ACCOMPLICE POURED SOUP ON
HIS HEAD.
WHAT?
>> MAYBE NEXT TIME THEY CAN GLUE
THEMSELVES TO A SOUP CAN WHILE
AN ARTIST PAINTS THEIR FACES.
THIS IS GETTING ABSURD AND THESE
PEOPLE SHOULD BE JAILED OR FINED
FOR DESTROYING OR ENDANGERING
WORKS OF GLOBAL IMPORTANCE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY GET AWAY
WITH THIS.
IT JUST -- IT HAPPENS ALMOST
EVERY WEEK AND MULTIPLE TIMES
THIS WEEK.
>> Laura: WELL, DON'T FORGET
TO TELL THAT TO OUR FRIENDS ON
CNN.
>> THAT'S GET AGO LOT OF
ATTENTION IN TERMS OF THE E
DEFACING ART WORK AND WHAT THAT
MEANS AND OVERALL OUR
CONVERSATION AND WHAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT TO YOU.
THIS ART OR THE LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF OUR PLANET?
>> ART AND SUSTAINABILITY ARE
NOT AT ODDS.
NOT AN EITHER OR AND DESTROY ART
TO SAVE THE PLANET.
ART SHOULD BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
AND THEY'RE USING IT AND ITS
DESTRUCTION FOR DIVISIVE
PURPOSE.
WE ALL SHOULD BE UNIFIED IN CON
TEMPORAL INTEGRATIONING THIS.
I'M SORRY >> Laura: IN HER
LOGIC, ANYTHING CAN BE DESTROYED
IF THE THEME BEHIND THE
DESTRUCTION IS SAVING THE PLANET
AND THAT MEANS ANY PERSON
FRANKLY BECAUSE IS ONE PERSON'S
LIFE ANYWAY AS IMPORTANT AS
SAVING THE PLANET?
IT'S A VERY UTILITARIAN APPROACH
TO THINGS, RAYMOND.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE ISIS
BOOKED ON THAT CNN SHOW.
FROM THE MISUSE OF PAINTINGS TO
THE MISUSE OF SONG, LAURA, THIS
IS A CLIMATE GROUP CALLED
EXTINCTION REBELLION BUT THEY
MAY AS WELL CALL THEMSELVES
MUSIC REBELLION.
>> Laura: OH MY GOD.
>> LAURA, IF YOU DO A FLASH MOB,
PICK A SONG FROM THIS CENTURY
AND MAKE SURE YOU KNOW THE
CHOREOGRAPHY.
LOOK OUTREBOUNDED THEY'RE KIND
OF TENTATIVE AND DON'T QUITE
KNOW WHEN TO LIFT THE LEG.
IT'S VERY SAD.
THE SONG THE EXTINCTION
REBELLION SHOULD HAVE BUILT
AROUND IN THIS GROUP IS THIS
ONE.
LAURA, THE MAN WHO WROTE THAT
SONG AND PRODUCE SOD MANY OF
THESE ICONIC CHRISTMAS SPECIALS
JULES BASS DIED AT 87 THIS WEEK
AND HE DIRECTED AND PRODUCING
EVERYTHING FROM THE GREAT 1964
RUDOLPH THE RED NOISED REINDEER
TO FROSTY THE SNOWMAN IN 1969
AND HE ALSO WROTE THE LYRICS FOR
SO MANY OF THE BELOVED SONGS PUT
ONE FOOT IN FRONT OF THE OTHER
AND I'M MR. SNOW MEISER.
WHATEVER I TOUCH TURNS TO COLD
IN MY CLUTCH.
WE ARE SANTA EASEFULS.
ALL THESE GREAT -- ELVES AND THE
BELOVED TOUCH STONES OF OUR
CHILDHOOD.
HE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT.
>> Laura: HE DIED AT 87 AND
JERRY LEE LEWIS OF COURSE PASSED
AWAY AT 87 TOO.
ICONS IN AMERICAN CULTURE AND
MUSIC.
>> LAURA, BEFORE WE GO, I CAN'T
LET THIS PASS, "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE" IS CELEBRATING FIVE YEARS
ON AIR THIS WEEKEND AND ANYONE
THAT'S BEEN A LONG TIME FAN OF
THIS SHOW KNOWS THAT WHILE YOU
HAD ONE THING GOING ALMOST EVERY
EPISODE THIS HAPPENED IN THE
EARLY YEARS OF THE SHOW.
>> Laura: MY EARRINGS ARE
FALLING OFF I'M LAUGHING SO HARD
HERE.
>> Laura: MY EARRING FELL,
ISN'T THAT FUN.
>> Laura: LEARNING ABOUT THIS
IN "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," A
FEDERAL DELEGATION -- MY EARRING
FELL OFF.
>> LAST WEEK HE SENT ME AND
SECRETARY POMPEO.
>> Laura: PEOPLE IN OFFICE,
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
MY EARRING FELL OFF I WAS SO
EXCITED ABOUT THAT TOPIC.
>> LAURA, I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
YOU BECAUSE THAT HASN'T HAPPENED
A SINGLE TIME IN 2022, BUT NOW
WE'RE MOVED ON FROM LOSING
EARRINGS TO, WELL, WE'RE LOSING
OTHER THINGS.
>> Laura: SHE SHOULD BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE JUST FOR
THAT.
AND WITH THAT MY LITTLE EAR
PIECE FELL OUT BUT GO AHEAD, I'M
LISTENING.
>> THAT WAS ON MONDAY.
WHAT'S WITH YOUR EARS, INGRAHAM?
>> OPEN CHANNELS THAT THINGS
DON'T CLING TO IN ANY WAY.
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, HAPPY
ANSWER VERSE REIGNS LEADING
AND -- ANNIVERSARY, YOU'VE BEGUN
INSTRUMENTAL TO THE TASK AND
IT'S BEEN AN AWESOME, AWESOME
FIVE YEARS AND I HOPE MANY MORE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF FUN.
THE SHOW BEHIND THE SHOW IS THE
NEXT SHOW.
>> WE'RE DOING A REALITY SHOW ON
THAT LATER.
CONGRATULATIONS, LAURA.
>> Laura: BA